well scientists say climate change is
getting worse and there could be serious
consequences for our planet in the next
20 years the new report from the UN
predicts that at the current warming
rate millions more people will die from
extreme heat by the year 2040 there will
also be substantial loss of coral reefs
and a rise of sea levels that could wipe
out small island nations like the
Bahamas and the Maldives more than 90
scientists from 40 countries wrote the
728 page report so me Nissen gupta is
the international climate reporter for
The New York Times and she's joining us
now good morning
good morning you know it's startling you
look at these numbers just by 2040 the
devastating effects that will already
see within our own lifetimes and
obviously our children how did
scientists come to this conclusion 2040
is exactly the year to keep in mind a
child born today will just be graduating
from college in 2040 my own daughter
will be in her early 30s in the 20 20 40
they came to this conclusion by looking
at piles and piles of scientific studies
and they concluded that we are warming
up the planet by human activity by
everything that we do so fast that we're
reaching the cliff edge a little faster
quite a bit faster so most of these
wounds are self-inflicted by us what are
we doing what warms up the planet
according to scientific consensus is
greenhouse gas emissions how the
greenhouse gas emissions get into the
atmosphere from cars and trucks from
planes from agriculture even produces
greenhouse gas emissions so and the
consequences are really quite dire once
the planet heats up to a certain level
you have much higher chances of heat
waves that can be potentially very fatal
wildfires the likes of which we have
seen this year coastal flooding because
of sea rise lots of people millions and
millions of people who live on the US
Coast and all around the world remember
we've got lots of capital for these lots
of airports along the coastlines those
are in danger and huge economic losses
when we also have the geopolitical
effects with that happen when you have
droughts and food shortages countries
start to go in and take the resource
of other countries you start to have all
kinds of conflicts as a result of these
effects you raise a very good point that
food shortages and water shortages can
lead to civil unrest and can pave the
way for much bigger conflicts absolutely
when I spoke with President Obama about
this in 2015 he said no challenge poses
a greater threat to future generations
than climate change and what he
specifically talked about to sort of
what you were talking I John the rise of
ocean levels anywhere five six seven
feet you have bread baskets essentially
the places that feed our country wiped
out then that can lead conflict and
terrorism he tied it to future terrorism
in this world I think a lot of people
have known for a long time what the
risks are as one scientist put it to me
long before this report came out she
said this is no longer a wake-up call
you know we should all be awake we
should all be woke by now on this now
the good news is that for a very long
time policymakers scientists politicians
have known exactly the main things that
need to be done right so they are hard
they're not easy because it means moving
the global economy really quickly really
profoundly that means weaning off of
things like using coal you and I don't
use coal but the world as a whole relies
on coal for like I write it is the
largest source the single largest source
of electricity so it means switching
from coal to renewable energy like solar
and wind it means figuring out how to
get from place a to place B without
putting oil in our in our cars there are
engineering solutions there are lots of
very smart scientists trying to figure
out how to suck that carbon out of the
atmosphere and there are non engineering
solutions like forests how to preserve
our forests which act as a huge carbon
so a big challenge is how to implement
those solutions that's right so it's an
issue of political will and can we do it
rather than do we know how to do yeah I
need a bigger appreciation for forests
because they're very important to saving
saving the world really people don't
make their connection thank you very
much so many so good to you good to have
you here you can find more information
on how you can help the environment on
our website CBS this morning calm